many gave me his but this is good no
hobby though
alright Wizards Silver Dollar wizard
where you from where'd you grow up
Washington DC and that's for your base
today I'm all over the globe but you
started in DC yeah how'd you grow up
yeah both your parents as a kid yeah
both my parents Rona how was your
childhood it was great let me tell it
hey I had a good time no crazy abuse
nothing like that nah none of that type
step at what point did you start working
as a pill when I was 21 rigid the idea
from friends or deaf role models my time
with it basically came from understands
if I bled for what and I got older up
whatever's apparent but I had other
cousins and stuff that was looking at
doing and stuff like that and they used
to be talked about it and riding down
the track and stuff like that and I used
to be just sitting back and getting high
and stuff and doing my thing when I was
doing this stuff in the streets but when
I was looking at the movies with them
and they talking about it I'd realize
that was me so then once I realized that
we had all type of chicks that we was
like running trains and [ __ ] on you know
doing stuff that young dudes do itself
with chicks and I picked one of the main
chicks that was really going like
rolling the stuff and I told her did you
wanna come [ __ ] with this pimping you
know we can get some money and [ __ ] like
that so she was with it and then from
there and I would just went and kept
growing up so even doing this for how
many years about 20
do what he do you have children yeah and
are you married no did he even arrested
for this before yeah
was that trafficking pandering pandering
yeah so you travel around the country
mmm how's it work in different cities
like in in Vegas you're in casinos yeah
work different in different cities you
know the casinos in Vegas then you got
to track some different states and stuff
like that with a prostitute so - OH -
host ro you got the Internet
you know it's all the type of way that
you can get money out of how to do how
many girls do you have in your stable
well I got like four girls that play
their part in my congregation yeah
what races are you girls black it's bad
it did you have sex with the girls yeah
so the pimp style has changed over the
years you seem to be from the old school
stylish dresser flashy car I got that
coming up under the last of the old
school brief you know nowadays like more
than young school you know the jord and
you know the young young young cats you
know the young dresses the ders is it
all that's like JIT you know but I guess
they just don't know no better you have
more style yeah they can't [ __ ] with me
where the qualities of pimp needs to
thrive the quality what personality
traits the being good when you didn't
need to be a good man period of all you
know you got another treat people and
you got to serve respected you want to
be respected back you know and you just
got want to be the best at whatever you
want do per you and a buddy nothing
anything what about the girls in your
stable we design what qualities do you
look for in a girl
Northy I like go get it like them to
have that business want to go get money
you know Anna listen you know they gotta
be able to listen so what's the
arrangement how much of their money do
you take a hundred percent I need it all
so it's the what's the girl get out of
it so you get think here she keep money
to I don't have a walk-around bro he's
grown women what do you do when one of
your girls gets out of line communicate
that's the key I won't put my hands on
no and what do you do when one of your
girls has a gets a customer who's giving
him a hard time gets in trouble well I
teach them how to handle itself when I'm
not around so they have to handle itself
and if it's a problem we I can't help
but I'm going over the fifth my chicks
like family do you think their
relationship a girl has with their pimp
is somewhat as somehow a substitute for
the relationship she had with her father
yes the appellee they call your daddy
definitely not all of them but a lot do
ya our drugs are part of the picture for
your girls
I don't like drugs part of the picture
but I don't even really accept girls
that dude your hard drugs what's the
craziest thing you've seen in all your
years of doing this the craziest thing I
say there's so many crazy things I mean
I mean eight crazy things it's like when
you talk about girls getting weight rods
and stuff like that and shot at and
stuff you know oh that's basically like
in the same category it's just is it's a
bad situation huh
and he goes down what's the longest one
of your girls has stayed with you three
years if you hadn't become a pimp what
what other careers do you think you you
might have followed I was always in the
streets to be honest so I never like
really working hard so like dealing
drugs and all that standing outside know
that I ain't really never was with that
you know I got to survive so I did what
I had to do with stuff but I like I
never like to work hard so no telling
what I be doing to be honest no telling
what I'll be doing
what are you proudest of in your life
the proudest of how I've changed my life
that's the proudest I changed my life
for the better and working my way out of
the streets and being more my kids like
and being able to take care of my kids
and stuff so I had to learn to elevate
my game to another level
cuz it's always gonna be in me I'm
always be the person that I am but I
just gotta learn I had to learn to put
myself in situations where I can't get a
no trouble and stuff like that and still
could beat me and still don't have to
work hard I think it still would be
successful and overall my kids love me
are you raising your kids yes I help
take care of them they don't stay with
me but you know I help take care and
they come visit me my kids getting older
and stuff like that so they come visit
me and I go visit they're there I move
around so much so I can just go pop up
on them and they get a notice I take a
problem with me
do they know what Dad does for a living
yeah I be honest with my kids about
everything dear boys or girls about what
happens if one of your kids decides to
follow in your footsteps or work for
somebody like yourself all I can do is
really talk to them like I told you
communication is the key so I call I can
do is talk to them and you know give
them other options you know let them
know other options that they can go and
you can still you know it's a lot of
ways to get money and get rich and
wealthy in you know so I just you know
showing other ways and stuff and let
them know stuff that I've been through
and that can come with it
and it's a good chance that can come
with it did you graduate high school yes
you started it what age again 21 I was
21 20 21 you tell me more about your
beginnings as a pimp yeah it went down
like I was telling you like we was
having girls that we was you know I had
like little roller chicks that everybody
was you know sleeping with stuff like
that and I got the main one that was
like the leader all the other girls and
stuff like that so when she was with it
she basically got put to the test cuz I
brought around you know people that was
already having sex with her stuff like
that but now we done you know
communicating we said we was gonna be on
the same page and we can get this money
together you know let's see how this
work when you get around now so once we
got around now she failed the test you
know and somebody had did something with
you did what I'm saying so like now I
was being tested on what I was gonna do
about the situation you know and I
checked the chick about the situation
after I checked er you know I had them
problems no more you know so that was a
test for me and her and it went on from
there and I just gradually kept growing
and growing and confidence kept getting
bigger and I always knew I could be the
best at whatever I did you know so
that's what we're down and we're gonna
keep this thing pushing alright wizard
silver dollar thank you so much for
sharing your story and good luck with
wherever you go from here
thanks for show it's all love yeah
Church
you